And the sons of Noah,
they went forth of the Ark were shem and
ham and Japheth and ham is the father of
Canaan.
These are the three sons of Noah and of
them was the whole earth.
Overspread and Noah began to be a hud,
husbands men,
and he planted a vineyard and he drank
of the wine and was drunk,
and he was uncovered within his tent and
Ham.
The father of Canaan saw the nakedness
of his father and told his two brethren
without friends,
Shem and Japheth took a garment and laid
upon both their shoulders and went
backward and covered the nakedness of
their father.
And their faces were backward and they
saw not their father's nakedness.
And Noah awoke from his wine and knew
what his younger son had done unto him.
And he said,
curse it to be Canaan.
A servant of servants,
shall he be unto his brethren.
And he said,
blessed shall be the Lord God of
chairman.
Canaan shall be his servant and God
shall enlarge Japheth.
And he shall dwell in the tents of Shem
and Canaan be his servant.
And no one lived after the flood,
350 years and all the days of Noah were
950 years and he died
and the whole earth was of one language
and of one speech.
Okay.
So I remember thinking about this story,
it's got to be 30 years ago
and I think the meaning of the story
stood out for me.
Sometimes when you read complicated
material,
sometimes a piece of it will stand out.
It's for some reason it's like it
glitters.
I suppose that might be one way of
thinking about it.
It's it,
it,
you're in sync with it and you can
understand what it means.
I've really experienced that reading the
Tao Te Ching,
which is document I would really like to
do a lecture on at some point because
some of the verses I don't understand,
but others stand right out and I can
understand them.
And I think I understood what this part
of the story of no amount.
And I think it means,
you know,
we talked a little bit about what
nakedness meant in the story of Adam and
eve.
And the idea essentially was that to
know yourself naked is to become aware
of your vulnerability,
the physical,
your physical boundaries in time and
space,
and your,
your,
your physiological,
your fundamental physiological
insufficiencies as they make might be
judged by others.
So there's biological insufficiency
that's sort of built into you because
you're a fragile mortal,
vulnerable half insane creature and
that's,
that's just an existential truth.
And then of course,
even merely as a human being,
even with all those faults,
there are faults that you have that are
particular to you that might be judged
harshly by the group while might be,
we'll definitely be judged harshly by
the group.
And so to become aware of your nakedness
is to become self conscious and,
and to,
to know your limits and to know your
vulnerability.
And that's what is revealed to when he
comes across his father naked.
It's.
So the question is,
what does it mean to see your father
naked?
And it seems to me,
and especially in an inappropriate
manner like this,
it,
it's,
it's as if ham,
he does the same thing that happens in
the Mesopotamian creation myth when when
timeout an absolute give rise to the
first God's there,
they're the father of the eventual
deity,
of,
of redemption,
Marduk there are very careless and noisy
and the kill app,
their father and attempt to inhabit his
corpse.
And that makes timeout enraged.
And so she bursts forth from the
darkness to,
to do the men.
It's like a precursor to the flood story
or an analog to the flood story.
And I see the same thing happening here
with him is that he's,
he's insufficiently respectful of his
father.
And the question is exactly what does
the farther represent.
And you can say,
well there's,
there's,
there's the father that you have and
that's a human being.
That's,
that's a man like other men,
a man among men.
But then there's the father as such.
And that's the spirit of the father.
And in so far as you have a father,
you have both at the same time.
You have the personal father that's a
man among other men,
just like anyone else,
there's father,
but in so far as that man is your
father,
that means that he's something different
than just another person and what he is
is the incarnation of the spirit of the
father and to see that,
to take it to what to disrespect that
carelessly.
Maybe even like no,
it makes a mistake,
right?
He produces wine and gets himself drunk
and you might say,
well,
you know,
if he sprawled out there for everyone to
see,
it's hardly hams fault if he stumbles
across it,
but the book is laying out a danger and
the danger is that,
well,
maybe you catch your father at his most
vulnerable moment and if you're
disrespectful then you transgress
against the spirit of the father and if
you transgress against the spirit of
father and lose the spirit of the father
and lose respect for the spirit of the
father,
then that is likely to transform you
into a slave.
That's a very interesting idea and I
think it's particularly interesting.
Maybe not particularly interesting,
but it's.
It's particularly Germane.
I think to our current cultural
situation,
because I think that were pushed
constantly to see the nakedness of our
father,
so to speak,
because of the intense criticism that's
directed towards our culture and the
patriarchal culture,
so to speak.
We're constantly exposing its weaknesses
and vulnerabilities and let's say
nakedness and there's nothing wrong with
criticism,
but the thing about criticism is the
purpose of criticism is to separate the
wheat from the chaff.
It's not the burn everything to the
ground,
right?
It's to say,
well,
we're going to carefully look at this.
We're going to carefully differentiate.
We're going to keep what's good and
we're gonna move away from what's bad,
but the point of the criticism isn't to
identify everything is bad.
It's two separate.
What's good from what's bad so that you
can retain what's good and move towards
it and to be careless at that is deadly
because you inhabited by the spirit of
the father.
Right?
In so far as you're a cultural
construction,
which of course is something that the.
That the postmodern,
Neo Marxists are absolutely in phatic
about.
You're a cultural construction in so far
as you're a cultural construction than
your inhabited by the spirit of the
father and to be disrespectful towards
that means to undermine the very
structure that makes you not all of what
you are.
Certainly certainly not all of what you
are,
but a good portion of what you are in so
far as you're a socialized cultural
entity and if you pull out the.
If you pull the foundation out from
underneath that,
what do you have left?
You can hardly manage on your own.
You know,
it's just not possible.
You're a cultural creation and so hamm
makes this desperate error and is
careless about exposing himself to the
vulnerability of his father.
Something like that.
He does it without sufficient respect
and the judgment is that not only will
he be a slave but so will all of his
descendants and he's contrasted with the
other two sons who I suppose are willing
to give their father the benefit of the
doubt.
Something like that.
And so when they see him in a
compromising position,
they handle it with respect and,
and,
and don't capitalize on it.
And maybe that makes them strong.
That's what it seems to me.
And so I think that's what that story
means.